de la farine de l'eau de la levure du
sel et vous obtenez une baguette
tradition celle ci est un peu
particulière puisque c'est la meilleure
des yvelines celui qui l'a façonné c'est
martial guégan un profil atypique
puisqu'il détient une licence de
mathématiques un master en management
cela fait seulement cinq ans qu'ils
travaillent dans cette entreprise
familiale à chatou à l'école primaire
les mercredis après midi je les passais
dans le fournil à faire des gâteaux ou
du parent
mais je n'avais envie de faire autre
chose à la base et plus j'avançais plus
une envie d'entreprendre me prenait et
j'avais cet appel vers ce savoir faire
et ce que je connais depuis tout petit
120 apprentis employés et chefs
d'entreprises ont participé à ce
concours
depuis dix ans les objectifs n'ont pas
changé promouvoir la baguette de
tradition française et l'artisanat
il ya nos cinq sens qu'ils sont en éveil
1 je veux dire quand vous passez devant
la boulangerie vous avez basse et
l'odorat évidemment avec les bonnes
effluves de vin du bons pains chauds
vous avez donc le visuel quand on la
découpe on doit avoir ce qu'on appelle
une mie alvéolé donc irrégulière et
sauvage
il ya quatre ans le jeune boulanger
avait déjà remporté le prix du meilleur
croissant des yvelines
cette année pour la baguette tradition
c'est sa recette secrète qui a sans
doute fait toute la différence
j'ai utilisé en fait une recette d'une
pré fermentation qui s'appelle sur
pouliches c'est une partie de la pâte
qu'on fait fermenter 48 heures à
l'avancé pour l'ajouter dans la pâte au
dernier moment pour faire le temps ça ça
permet de donner plus de goût
l'année prochaine sa baguette tradition
représentera les yvelines au concours
national